ja man kann das jetzt schon sehen ganz
deutlich und klar es ist so da ist keine
100 tage schonfrist natürlich auch nicht
von der cdu ist auch völlig in ordnung
auch nicht von den journalisten ist
genau so in ordnung aber wir müssen
sehen dass hat es eigentlich noch nie
gegeben wir haben kroner krise wir haben
finanziell sehr an spannende zeiten die
haben die frage aktuell ist olympia bei
kurz wir haben die frage was passiert
der ukraine an der russischen grenze da
sind viele dinge die jetzt auf diese
regierung zu kommen da kann es keine 100
tage schonfrist geben sondern muss von
vorne herein ran weil wir sehr sehr viel
tun müssen und das heißt auch für diese
regierung klar wahrzunehmen hier gibt es
keine große erholung vielleicht eine
kurze weihnachtspause aber spätestens ab
neuer muss weiter gearbeitet werden dann
kann man hoffen dass man gute aktive
sowie hier auch für die opposition hat
die guckt wo die fehler sind und es war
nachher noch besser zu machen ja herr
fricke also ich glaube wir sind alle der
gleichen meinung also was die krone hat
es noch nicht gegeben und ist eine
weltweite krise ich hab übrigens keines
aber ich bin ein bisschen erkältet haben
ja auch noch testen lassen
gleichzeitig muss ich ihnen
widersprechen denn viele viele
bundesregierung die in amt und würden
gekommen sind hatten überhaupt keine
schonfrist ein beispiel rot grün damals
stand davor den ersten krieg tatsächlich
oder kriegsbeteiligung irgendwo im
ausland mit natürlich im ausland dann
immer mit deutscher beteiligung dann
eben leisten zu müssen kriegerische
handlungen mit dem kosovo krieg ist es
dazu bekommen es war absehbar bei der
regierungsübernahme dass das stelle ich
war wahrscheinlich der fall sein würde
sie erinnern sich an helmut kohl der
jahr 1982 damals auf dem höhepunkt der
auseinandersetzung zwischen ost und west
und der innerdeutschen
auseinandersetzung zwischen nachrüstung
oder nicht nachrüstungen diese massiven
friedensdemonstrationen die gegeben die
es gegeben hat ins amt kam und das
durchgesetzt hat oder nur noch ein
beispiel helmut schmid der damals
1974 insgesamt kam als eine große
weltwirtschaftskrise gab von den
innerdeutschen problem damals mit
guillaume gar nicht zu sprechen also ich
glaube diese beispiele zeigen dass jede
regierung gerne diese 100 tage hätte ich
würde mir auch wünschen dass sie von
journalistischer seite diese 100 tage
bekommen weil das wäre fair aber da sich
was die politik an die die gibt keine
100 tage schonfrist da ist man zu
verändern da ist doch ein schöner punkte
sitzt er neben dem die politik chef also
hier an gibst du 100 tage schonfrist
jetzt als journalist béla anda sagt das
wäre eigentlich mal ganz schön also seht
ihr sicherlich braucht auch die
ampelkoalition eine bilanz nach 100
tagen das ist ganz klar die muss man
geben aber ehrlich gesagt regiert die
ampel ja gefühlt schon viel länger als
erst seit heute das hat sie
möglicherweise unbewusst oder auch ganz
bewusst genauso gestaltet die chefs von
spd grünen und fdp wir erinnern uns
optimal war am 26 september zwei tage
später gab es dieses berüchtigt berühmt
berüchtigtes selphy photo schon der
beiden parteichefs annalena baerbock
robert habeck und christian lindner und
volker wissing so damit war die ampel
fast schon man riskiert auch wir haben
etwa damit war klar dass die beiden und
das wird jetzt immer mehr vergessen die
beiden machen es zusammen und wer auch
immer mit ihnen kuriert ist in dieser
koalition der kleinen sarah kreuz neben
tage heil machen ist so da müssen wir
einmal darauf eingehen weil das ist
natürlich nicht während der nummer die
gerade natürlich die beiden auch
versuchen zu erzielen hat nicht so ganz
funktioniert aber fast natürlich dass im
grunde wir beide müssen uns einig sein
soweit das narrativ also wie fdp und mir
grüne und dann ist im grunde egal wer
unter uns kannst er sie verlassen hat
ein bisschen die verträge das ist aber
sicher dass an dem dienstagabend wenige
stunden zuvor markus söder bereits
jamaika abgepfiffen hatte er hat nämlich
gesagt wir werden mario nagler
bereitstehen das war dienstagmittag aber
das haben wir noch vor der
bundestagswahl immer auf jeden fall
dienstagabend war klar es geht
eigentlich nur noch für jeden der da
einigermaßen politisch denkt geht nur
noch richtung ampel ich hoffe dass nur
von kleinen leute sagen die cdu hätte
eine faire chance gehabt wenn sie sich
nicht nehmen wollte gerne aber wir haben
das wir reden jetzt natürlich werden
auch wir haben jetzt ja nicht über die
frage jamaika oder rot sondern wir reden
über die frage hat die regierung 100
tage schonfrist und nicht und mein punkt
war ja nur zu sagen dass sie gefühlt ja
als fdp grüne und spd schon viel länger
an der macht sind und regieren stichwort
epidemische lage der erste gesetzentwurf
die er vorgelegt wurde als sie offiziell
noch in koalitionsverhandlungen waren
aber ihre macht im bundestag ja
möglicherweise auch zu recht schon
genutzt haben also dass die ampel jetzt
erst mit dem heutigen tag regiert stimmt
nicht sie regiert einige shows sind voll
ausschöpft anfang november ab jetzt gibt
es keine ausreden mehr aber nein ich
glaube das ist immer so ein narrativ
seiner erzählung die jetzt ganz bewusst
gestrickt wird also die union hatte
hätte die chance gehabt und die union
hat das selber verpasst also ihr hättet
ihr wollt damit haben wir haben wir klar
gesagt es wird aber für mich aber im
moment mein wald dafür hat mich alles
sagte armin laschet wird es nicht mehr
was man was man was man sieht also die
fdp ist glaube ich auch von vielen cdu
wählern gewählt worden dies auch im
bürgerhaus auch keiner cdu-wähler die
stimme an den bürgern der cdu-mehrheit
sind aber weder von der cdu zur fdp
gewandert sind ihre eigenen habe ich
glaube wir müssen jetzt nicht irgendwie
weg messer rennen alles finden immer
normaler ist sind nicht die na ja
irgendwie werden haben wir stehen hier
die gewichtung in der wähler vielleicht
einmal kurz einsatz außerdem das ganze
nennen also es sind wähler sehr stark
von der cdu zur fdp gegangen ein und die
haben gesagt wir haben die hoffnung ist
die fdp eine bürgerliche politik umsetzt
und im idealfall mit der cdu und da hat
die fdp sehr sehr schnell gesagt sie
möchte in einer ampelkoalition sie
möchte rot-grün verlängern was ja auch
das recht der fdp es aber ich glaube da
die fdp einige enttäuscht und wenn ich
mir so einige kapitel ihrem
koalitionsvertrag anschaut zum beispiel
zur migrationspolitik glaube ich nicht
dass das im sinne der fdp wähler ist
dass er in zukunft die illegale
migration nach deutschland und europa
befördert werden soll dass zum beispiel
es einfacher werden soll nach
deutschland zu kommen und gleichzeitig
auch noch die leistungen für diejenigen
die hier asyl bekommen unreflektiert
ausgeweitet werden das schafft anreize
dass in jedem menschen sagen wir wollen
unbedingt nach deutschland kommen die
wir gar nicht unbedingt brauchen und ich
halte es für ganz wichtig dass man
unterscheidet zwischen einer
qualifizierten fachkräfte zuwanderung
sehr gut asyl sehr gut dass wir aber
gleichzeitig auch die grenzen stark
kontrollieren denn wir müssen auch
entscheiden wen wir nach deutschland
holen absolut genau richtig der erste
teil war nur entschuldigung das war csu
wahlprogramm was hier vorgetragen haben
nicht koalitionsvertrag und bei der
frage was sage ich jetzt noch mal
deutlich es gibt keinen cdu wähler denen
dann eine andere partei mal ausgeliehen
bekommt es gibt auch kein fdp-wähler den
eine andere partei ausgeben wie im
bekommt und wenn man sich die
wählerwanderungen der wahl ankommt sagt
wer hat früher mal cdu gewählt aber
jetzt gerade hat die celina martin
reißig dann hatte er hat die das ist
richtig aber noch ich hoffe doch dass
ein wähler selbst wenn der stammwähler
ist sich jedes mal überlegt was machen
sie es nicht werden sie immer gleich
nein aber ich glaube ich kann sagen ich
schon im ziel ist gewinnt
er werde nicht fdp geht nicht mehr ziehe
ich einmal fdp beim springen in einem
sehr persönlichen umfeld gibt es auch
zwei unions wähler die das erste mal fdp
gelegen haben und nicht weil sie die fdp
so toll finden sondern weil sie von der
union zu sehr enttäuscht sind weil ihre
freiheit ihnen genommen wurde kann aber
in einer warenhaus denn die gemeinsamen
wie hoch natürlich dass die fdp das die
fdp den menschen ein angebot gemacht hat
dass sie den menschen
aber so ist es ja und wenn man sich
diese frage gestellt da muss man noch
sagen woran hat es gelegen und kann
müssen wir aufklären afrika hat davon
profitiert und seine partei sondern muss
man sagen wir im offenbar ein besseres
angebot gemacht als sie den hatten sonst
sehe ich solche rekordverluste auch in
hamburg ich bin ja völlig der meinung
wir müssen das alles auch sehr
selbstkritisch betrachten kundig in der
fröhlich und gründlich aufarbeiten
völlig richtig völlig richtig und ich
glaube auch es gab unterschiedliche
gründe auf der einen seite
personalauswahl nach einer bin logik man
hat nicht mehr sich richtig klar mit
position in die politische arena begeben
hat er versucht manchmal vielleicht
rot-grün mainstream hinterher zu laufen
hat die fdp das muss man anerkennen im
wahlkampf klare position im sinne von
vier bürgerlichen wählern bezogen worum
es mir aber jetzt ja ging ist dass viele
bürgerliche wähler auch die fdp gewählt
haben in der hoffnung dass zum beispiel
bei den sozialen sicherungssystemen
reformen durchgeführt werden und die
aktien rente mit verlaub die wird ja die
probleme die in den nächsten jahren auf
uns zukommen nicht lösen aber er
unterstützt und sie finde ich gut die
aktie machte der punkt aber trotzdem
werden die anderen punkte nicht
angegangen und ich glaube meine hoffnung
ist die fdp auch gewählt worden und bei
der migration glaube ich hätten sich
auch viele fdp-wähler was anderes
gewünscht und deswegen glaube ich hat
die fdp jetzt schon auch ein problem das
zu kommunizieren was dann einigen teilen
im koalitionsvertrag steht und ich
glaube das problem der kommunikation
wird die frage sein was wir machen und
was wir nicht machen der
koalitionsvertrag ist da eigentlich
ziemlich nah an dem was im wahlprogramm
drin steht und bei der frage
wen wir als migranten brauchen wir
brauchen massen auf dem bereich
qualifizierter migration leute und ich
habe eigentlich die sogenannte neue cdu
so verstanden dass sie das auch so sieht
oder wie bei der ah ja dann sieht man
auch da wieder eigentlich eine reine
frage abschiebung sage ich ganz klar wer
ist denn der minister der am meisten ab
schiebt das ist ein fdp minister aus
nordrhein westfalen der die aufgabe
übernommen hat weil kein cdu minister in
nordrhein-westfalen sie machen wollte
man muss beides tun da sind wir gar
nicht weit auseinander und die frage was
denn in dieser koalition ein gesetz
genug passiert daran muss man erst mal
ich will mal ein beispiel im
koalitionsvertrag nennt dann kann man
danach ruhig versichert zu bilden hier
in anspruch dass deutschland zu kommen
dann kann man erst mal ins land kommen
das steht jetzt im koalitions hinein und
das wird schon die daumen einlesen kam
aber das ist doch offenkundig wir gucken
uns das gesetz an und dann treffen und
dann entscheide ich habe eine frage
nämlich zum koalitionsvertrag bilde ich
habe ja letztens mit den älteren
unionspolitikern dem hinteren gespräch
geführt und da haben die gesagt der
koalitionsvertrag ist eigentlich nicht
mein stil zehnte wer hat dies ist und
jetzt mit ihr immer auf den
koalitionsvertrag verwiesen und die
haben übrigens öfter mit
koalitionsvertrag verhandelt aus deiner
politische expertise erfahrung wie viel
ist denn so ein koalitionsvertrag
unbedingt detailreiche hier wird
eigentlich mehr da haben die die ich
natürlich schön ins bockshorn gejagt das
würden sie sicher nie über ihren
eigenheiten
koalitionsvertrages im hintergrund
würden sie sicher nie über ihren eigenen
koalitionsvertrag sagen damit das muss
also
das ist natürlich war es gibt
koalitionsverträge die werden nicht wie
eine bibel so eins zu eins umgesetzt der
unterschied hier ist aber dass sich hier
drei parteien die sich sicherlich nicht
so außer in rheinland-pfalz vorgefunden
haben zusammengesetzt haben und wirklich
irre themen durchdekliniert haben und
gesagt haben wir machen die kleinen
kunden model nach dem motto machen wir
die hälfte von dem was ich will dann
kriegst du die hälfte von dem was du
willst sondern die haben ihre bereiche
definiert das ist für uns wichtig grüne
das ist bei uns wichtig fdp-fraktion
rente freecards erwähnt und das ist für
die spd wichtig und dann haben sie
gesagt okay das schreiben wir so fest in
den koalitionsvertrag deswegen hat der
koalitionsvertrag eine ganz andere
wirkung auch nicht bindend was jedes
wort angeht aber natürlich was die
grundsätzliche ausrichtung angeht schon
und das unterscheidet ihn von allen
anderen koalitionsverträgen unter
anderem auch den von rot-grün 2002 und
1998 für afrika hätte lieber koaliert
mit der cdu/csu das haben sie denn ich
hätte gerne mag ich hätte gerne mit mit
armin laschet koaliert weil ich ihnen
übrigens bei den koalitionsverhandlungen
in nrw wo ich im präsidium als
landesschatzmeister jetzt
zusammengearbeitet habe und ich ihm
vertraue ich tue das auch heute noch vor
allen dingen wenn ich sehen welcher
gentleman art er über die dinge redet
die jetzt passiert sind auch über sein
eigenes scheitern beziehungsweise ich
immer gerne sage gescheitert werden kann
ist das erste mal richtig ihn haben will
ich habe keine ahnung was natürlich
würde es knallen wenn es nicht knallt
dann wären wir ja alle in derselben
partei es wird klar das ist ja natürlich
es ist doch klar dass bis weihnachten
oder erst im neuen jahr ich sag mal so
das hängt davon ab wie professionell
weiter geht wird und für mich war
überraschend ich bin seit 2002
abgeordneter ich war von 96 referent
gehört auch zu denen die helmut kohl
noch live erlebt haben in der politik
ich habe es nicht erlebt das so
professionell koalitionsverhandlungen
geführt worden sind ohne dass was
rauskam ich war selber in zwei
arbeitsgruppen habe gesehen wie das
aufgebaut worden ist wie man texte
erarbeitet hat das so durfte sich klingt
erstmal mit farblichen hintergrund lagen
gegen gemacht am ende eine lösung
gefunden wenn diese professionalität
weiter bleibt dann wird das noch lange
dauern bis man wirklich da sich streitet
die andere frage ist wir sind alle
menschen und da werden sicherlich alle
auch mal fehler machen